Ці хлопці й дівчата в Україні лише кілька тижнів. Вони - білоруси, новобранці полку Кастуся Калиновського,
який воює у складі ЗСУ. Рекрути вчаться поводитися зі зброєю і влучати в ціль.
Поруч тренуються більш досвідчені побратими. Вони закінчують півторамісячну підготовку.
Працюєте у двійках. П'ять патронів - зміна.
П'ять патронів - зміна.
Двійками повертаєтеся назад. Плюс? - Плюс.
Більшість із цих хлопців ніколи не служили в армії, але поводяться впевнено.
Контакт на 12!  - Контакт на 12!
Білоруси просять не показувати їхні обличчя.
Чимало в кого на батьківщині залишилися рідні.
У Білорусі полк Калиновського вважається екстремістським формуванням.
Зв'язок із ним - вкрай небезпечний.
20-річний боєць із позивним "Гіннес" знає, про що йдеться.
Я спав, і до мене завалилися, виламавши двері, співробітники державних органів.
Потім я отримав 15 діб адміністративного арешту.
Тому що ініціатива, у якій я брав участь, була більшою мірою антивоєнною.
Її підтекст був доволі лівим, тобто анархістським, тому їх давно цікавила ця ініціатива.
Періодично вони закривали людей через цю ініціативу.
Торік "Гіннес" виїхав з Білорусі до Грузії.
Уже там за допомогою чат-боту в Телеграмі долучився до полку Калиновського й через Польщу приїхав в Україну.
Абсолютно будь-який білорус може вступити в полк Кастуся Калиновського.
Питали лише якусь особисту інформацію, на твою думку, наскільки твій фізичний стан дозволяє, куди хочеш.
Будь-який білорус знадобиться, для нього завжди буде тут робота, не тільки воювати.
Ми "накатами" рухаємося до цілі, у якийсь момент щось станеться.
"Гіннес", ви медик "Альфи". "Дрезден", ви медик "Браво".
"Гіннес" ще не знає, що чекає на нього на справжній війні, але зараз його завдання - забрати пораненого з поля бою.
У нас триста! Ми евакуюємо і криємо!
Живий! Хе-хе…
Надати першу допомогу побратимам повинен уміти кожен військовий.
Боєць із позивним "Жартівник", як у героя з фільму Кубрика, записує дані про травми в картку пораненого.
Хлопець каже, що підготовка на полігоні просувається повільно через брак інструкторів.
Йому хотілося б швидше стати до бою, хоч і розуміє, що це може означати.
Я розраховую потрапити у штурмовики, і в такому разі не варто сподіватися й сильно розраховувати на те, щоб повернутися… взагалі живим.
У середині травня, п'ятеро "калиновців" не повернулися з Бахмута.
Тож мало хто тут, на полігоні, замислюється про те, як їхатиме назад, у Білорусь.
Тим паче за авторитарного режиму.
"Ось Україна напала, її підтримує НАТО, а Росія з цим впоратися не може,
бо в неї вже немає ресурсів, а що буде далі, а ми нічого не знаємо, а навіщо воно треба"…
Коли сидиш у Білорусі, то сидиш, як у болоті. І воно тебе тягне, тягне, тягне, і все так погано.
А коли вже такі думки починаються, то це дзвіночок, що треба щось міняти.
"Кажан", історик за освітою, виїхав з Білорусі до Європи рік тому через острах мобілізації і переслідування за антивоєнну позицію.
Він вважає Росію спільним ворогом українців і білорусів, бачення перемоги теж поділяє з українцями.
Перемога, я вважаю, це коли Україна відійде на свої межі до 1991 року,
коли буде здобутий Крим і Донбас й інші окуповані території.
Ми навіть жартували: "Ну, що, хлопці, улітку підемо на кримські пляжі!"
Бо настрій у нас добрий, ми підтримуємо один одного, і в нас таке почуття братерства, почуття єднання є.
Тим часом для рекрутів готують нове завдання.
Важливо кулеметнику лягти так, щоб він сектор свій тримав, щоб він міг працювати.
Група з восьми бійців має піти на штурм позицій. Опісля - правильно відступити.
Навчальною операцією керує командир полку Калиновського - Денис Прохоров із позивним "Кит".
У нас буде команда "скручування в укриття".
Укриття всі знають де, я показував. Починаючи справа, по одному.
"Кит" приїхав в Україну в 2014 році, тоді йому було 19.
Згодом приєднався до полку "Азов", воював на Сході, став військовим інструктором.
Денис каже: рекрутів полку Калиновського готують на такому ж рівні, як колись готували "азовців", хоч ті й починають "з нуля".
Зараз я бачу, як хлопці вже з кулеметом бігають, бачу, як вони справляються з проблемами зі зброєю,
це трапляється, вони не губляться, це класно саме в умовах, коли є постріли - це гучно, насамперед.
Полк Калиновського не може собі дозволити проводити відбір до своїх лав:
беруть усіх охочих білорусів, навчають, знаходять відповідну роботу.
Щомісяця з Польщі приїжджає нова група рекрутів - це 10-20 людей.
Що мотивує білорусів? За що вони воюють в Україні?
Про це ми з Денисом говоримо у більш спокійній обстановці.
Це питання надії білоруського народу на перемогу над режимом Лукашенка.
Також ми з хлопцями цим підрозділом намагаємося показувати українцям, що білоруси - це друзі, в першу чергу.
Це ніякі не "лукашисти". Серед білорусів є багато тих, хто підтримує Україну.
Ми намагаємося своїми вчинками, проливаючи кров, піт, намагаємось це також довести.
Полк Калиновського "вийшов" з тероборони "Азова" в березні торік.
Тоді до Києва прибуло чимало білоруських добровольців.
ГУР запропонувало їм створити окремий підрозділ у складі "Інтернаціонального легіону".
Нині полк Калиновського - це кілька сотень бійців - два бойові батальйони.
Вони мають військові квитки й офіційні контракти.
У складі полку є група БПЛА, мінометників, навіть власна артилерія.
А також - силовий резерв у Білорусі.
Це люди, які заповнюють анкети, вони знаходяться в Білорусі і просто заповнюють анкети і чекають "години ікс",
коли буде надіслано план дій, що робити тим, хто в резерві.
Ми будемо сподіватися, що ці люди, які заповнили анкети,
ми можемо на них так само покластися в певний час.
Про рейди на білоруську територію, як це роблять російські добровольці, "калиновці" поки не замислюються.
Кажуть, чекають, поки режим Лукашенка всерйоз захитається.
Лукашенко дуже переживає і боїться нашого підрозділу, бо він розуміє,
що це не просто групка якихось там страйкболістів, які приїхали погратися у війнушку, десь побігати з прикладами.
Це хлопці, які приїжджають з метою визволити Білорусь, визволити в першу чергу від нього.
І він розуміє, що ми, ці хлопці, які набираємося бойового досвіду, не будемо балакати з квіточками.
Бо ці хлопці, які приїдуть, будуть розмовляти з ним по-іншому.
Рекрути поки що про це не замислюються.
Вони повернулися до табору після тренувань під палючим сонцем і смакують "польовий" плов із закрутками -
гостинцями від місцевої ТрО.
На війні проти спільного ворога - вони готові віддячити.